foreign
[Music]
for Monday November 21st I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
over two dozen workers at meta have been
fired or disciplined as part of an
internal investigation by company
Executives into the misuse of an
internal system known as oops
that's according to people familiar with
the matter and documents viewed by The
Wall Street Journal the abuse of that
system raises questions about how much
control and access some meta staff and
contractors have to users data joining
us to discuss this wsj exclusive is our
reporter Kirsten grind hi Kirsten thanks
for coming on the show thanks so much
for having me can you start by telling
us a little bit more about this oops
system yes it's short for online
operations and it's this internal meta
system that allows employees and
contractors to basically file an
internal request almost like a complaint
when there's a problem with their or
like a friend or family's Facebook or
Instagram account one way to think of it
is like a concierge helpline right if
you lost your password if your account
has been hacked but again only for
Insider at meta and only for their
friends and family what do we know about
how the system was misused
what meta has been investigating for
over a year is this issue where through
the oops Channel if you're an employee
or a contractor you would have access to
a user's account which you can do
through that channel and so rather than
using that to say help a user some of
these employees and contractors were
misusing it they were getting into user
accounts often with the purpose of
taking the accounts over and reselling
them sometimes for a lot of money can
you tell us a little bit more about how
we know this information
so my colleague and I Bob McMillan we've
actually been looking into this for
quite a long time because we kind of
couldn't believe that actual employees
and contractors some of whom were
physical security guards so not really
people who normally would have access to
meta systems that this was happening and
so we spent a lot of time calling around
and talking to various parties and we
learned through the course of that that
this was actually an issue that meta has
been investigating for some time you
know for the people who were victims of
the misuse of this oop system what was
the experience like for them
so
meta is notorious for its terrible
customer service meaning they actually
have almost no customer service so
unfortunately there's a frequency in
which users either get locked out of
their account or are hacked or something
as simple as losing your password and
there's just literally no one you can
contact at meta by phone or email now
meta is working on this they say they're
committed to building this out but right
at this moment there's not anything like
that so for the user you actually have
no idea if it's an actual bad actor
hacker that's gotten into your account
or now maybe what we're revealing is it
could actually have been a meta employee
right now we're saying we know of more
than two dozen employees and contractors
over the last year so I don't want to
give the mistaken impression that
there's widespread misuse of the system
by meta employees but as a user you
would just basically be you know having
issues with your account that you can't
fix and in a lot of cases you just lose
your account because you can't get
through to anyone
what steps has meta taken to deal with
the situation
so as part of this investigation they've
actually fired and or disciplined we say
more than two dozen employees and
contractors and so they've been at this
for quite a long time looking into it
they're clearly aware it's an issue
they've told us that this is not
something that they will tolerate on any
of their platforms and that they'll
continue to go after these types of
people and you mentioned some of those
people were contractors what has the the
contracting company said about the
situation so the company is called
Allied Universal and they literally just
provide security guards stationed at
meta properties but the thing is
accessing this oops platform was kind of
a perk of the job and so what happened
there is like some people were abusing
it so Allied has told us they don't
stand for that and they won't tolerate
abuse either I mean what what is this
situation then tell us about kind of our
access and control of you know what we
think of as our own personal data and to
these social media pages that can be so
important to us personally or you know
even for some businesses I mean it's
true unfortunately that you can lose
access and not get it back there's ways
and we helpfully put something online at
the Wall Street Journal website to
protect your account from hackers and to
make sure you have the right Security on
there so you don't lose your account or
you don't find yourself in a situation
where you're trying to contact Facebook
or Instagram with no customer service
but at the end of the day you know it's
their platform and there's not a lot of
recourse at this point
for losing your account or anything like
that
all right that's our reporter Kirsten
Grine thanks so much for explaining this
to us thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]